THOSE DOCUMENTS INCLUDE 67
MARKED CONFIDENTIAL 92 MARKED
SECRET AND 25 MARKED TOP SECRET.
JOINING ME NOW CNN SENIOR LEGAL
ANALYST ELLIE HONING.
FROM FRIDAY OVER THE WEEKEND THE
BLANKS KEEP GETTING FILLED IN,
WE KNOW MORE THAN WE DID BEFORE.
FIRST OFF, WE NOW HAVE MORE
DETAILS ABOUT WHAT WAS TAKEN
FROM MAR-A-LAGO WAY BACK IN
JANUARY OR HANDED OVER.
>> RIGHT, JOHN.
MONDAY MORNING, CLASS BACK IN
SESSION, WE ARE INTO ADVANCED
LEVEL CLASSES.
I THINK ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS WE LEARNED IS WHAT WAS
TAKEN IN THOSE INITIAL 15 BOXES
BY THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES WHICH
LED TO DOJ GETTING INVOLVED, WE
NOW KNOW WHY THIS BECAME
CRIMINAL WHICH LED TO THE
SUBPOENA WHICH THEN LED TO THE
SEARCH WARRANT.
SO WE LEARNED THAT IN THAT
VISUAL BATCH OF 15 BOXES THE
ARCHIVES SEIZED 184 TOTAL
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS INCLUDING
25 DOCUMENTS AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL OF CLASSIFICATION, TOP
SECRET AND WITHIN THAT GROUP
THERE ARE HIGHLY SENSITIVE
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING A LOT OF
ACRONYMS IN THIS DOCUMENTS
RELATING TO HCS, HUMAN
INTELLIGENCE CONTROL SYSTEM,
SPIES, OUR AGENTS OUT THERE IN
THE WORLD PUTTING THEMSELVES AT
RISK.
FISA WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY WIRE
TAPS RELATING TO FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE ISSUES.
ALSO A COUPLE OTHER INTERESTING
DETAILS AND NUGGETS BURIED
WITHIN THIS AFFIDAVIT.
WE LEARNED THAT SEVERAL OF THE
DOCUMENTS ALSO APPEARED --
CONTAINED WHAT APPEARS TO BE
FPOTUS FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP'S HANDWRITTEN NOTES.
WERE THOSE FROM WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT WHICH WOULD NOT BE A
BIG DEAL, OR AFTERWARDS WHICH
WOULD SHOW HE WAS ACCESSING
THESE DOCUMENTS AT MAR-A-LAGO.
ANOTHER REALLY INTERESTING NOTE
WAS THAT HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
RECORDS WERE UNFOLDERED, DO YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS?
>> NOT IN FOLDERS.
>> INTERMIXED WITH OTHER
RECORDS.
AGAIN THAT IS CORRECT SHOWS THAT
PEOPLE WERE HANDLING AND
ACCESSING THESE DOCUMENTS WHILE
THEY WERE DOWN IN FLORIDA.
>> WE ALSO LEARNED ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF WITNESSES AND THE
TYPES OF WITNESSES HERE.
>> WE LEARNED THROUGH A LITTLE
BIT OF PROSECUTOR SPEAK,
PROSECUTORS ARE BEING A BIT
OPAQUE I THINK ON PURPOSE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF CIVILIAN
WITNESSES, A BROAD RANGE OF
CIVILIAN WITNESSES.
FIRST OF ALL, CIVILIAN WITNESSES
MEANS NOT FBI AGENTS WHO
SOMETIMES ARE YOUR WITNESSES FOR
THESE THINGS BUT REGULAR PEOPLE.
NOW, A BROAD RANGE A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER WE CAN'T PUT A NUMBER ON
THAT, BUT NO WAY A PROSECUTOR
USES THAT LANGUAGE FOR ONE
WITNESS OR TWO WITNESSES.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A GOOD
NUMBER.
THIS JUMPED OUT AT ME.
DOJ WRITES IN THE AFFIDAVIT THAT
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT HARMS
INCLUDING RETALIATION,
INTIMIDATION AND HARASSMENT AND
EVEN THREATS TO THEIR PHYSICAL
SAFETY, BUT HERE IS THE
IMPORTANT PART, AS THE COURT HAS
ALREADY NOTED THESE CONCERNS ARE
NOT HYPOTHETICAL MEANING THOSE
THINGS HAVE ALREADY HAPPENED TO
WITNESSES.
>> REFERENCES TO OBSTRUCTION
INSIDE THE AFFIDAVIT.
>> UNWASHINGTON FOOTBALL TEAM
BASES FOR GETTING THIS AFFIDAVIT
IS CONCERNS ABOUT OBSTRUCTION.
OF COURSE, TAMPERING WITH
WITNESSES WOULD COUNT BUT THERE
IS ALSO A CONCERN ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH DOCUMENTS.
THEY INCLUDE A LETTER FROM DOJ
TO DONALD TRUMP'S LAWYERS BACK
IN JUNE ASKING THAT A ROOM AT
MAR-A-LAGO WHERE THE DUPED HAD
BEEN SECURED AND ALL THE BOXES
BE IN THAT ROOM IN THEIR CURRENT
CONDITION.
THE DOJ SAYS KEEP THESE HERE,
KEEP THEM SECURE, DON'T MOVE
THEM.
WE LEARNED IN THE SEARCH WARRANT
THAT DOJ SAID WE NEED TO SEARCH
IN ALL THESE DIFFERENT AREAS
INCLUDING A STORAGE ROOM IN THE
RESIDENTIAL SUITE, PINE HALL,
DONALD TRUMP'S OFFICE AND OTHER
SPACES.
MAGGIE HABERMAN REPORTED THEY
DID FIND DOCUMENTS IN THE CLOSET
OF DONALD TRUMP'S OFFICE SO THAT
SUGGESTS THOSE BOXES AND
DOCUMENTS HAD BEEN MOVED AROUND.
>> THERE WAS A SURPRISE
INCLUSION IN THE FILING ON
FRIDAY WHICH WAS ACTUALLY A
LETTER FROM TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS.
>> THIS IS A LETTER FROM DONALD
TRUMP'S ATTORNEY OWES WHERE THEY
SAY TO DOJ, HEY, WITH HE WANT
YOU TO KNOW IN OUR VIEW A
PRESIDENT HAS ABSOLUTE AUTHORITY
TO DECLASSIFY DOCUMENTS.
NOW, AS A LEGAL MATTER THAT MAY
BE TRUE, THERE'S BEEN A LONG
DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER THE
ABSOLUTE IS ABSOLUTE OR VERY
BROAD.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S MISSING FROM
HERE, ANY ASSERTION THAT HE
ACTUALLY DID DECLASSIFY THE
DOCUMENTS WHICH IS PART OF IT
AND OF COURSE REMEMBER WE'VE HAD
REPORTING THAT 18 FORMER WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIALS HAVE SAID THAT
THERE WAS NEVER ANY SUCH ORDER,
COMPLETELY FICTION, NONSENSE,
RIDICULOUS, BS, LAUGHABLE.
IT IS HIGHLY DOUBTFUL THAT THAT
HAPPENED.
>> VERY QUICKLY IN 20 SECONDS OR
LESS, THE SPECIAL MASTER, A
JUDGE SEEMS INCLINED TO GRANT
THAT.
>> NOT SURPRISING THIS IS NOT AN
OUTRAGEOUS REQUEST.
IF IT IS GRANTED IT MEANS THOSE
DOCUMENTS WILL BE FILTERED,
REVIEWED BY A SPECIAL MASTER, AN
OUTSIDE INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY
WHO WILL DETERMINE WHETH